justement on va faire un but pas vu sur
lucas et vous allez voir c'est ouf c'est
parti le veut pas
expo l'ami jean luc lahaye en slip chez
christophe dechavanne regardez je me
déshabille
bon
c'est vrai vous le plus
[Applaudissements]
qui
douze mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non
à
benjamines et le titre qu alléchante est
une artiste dans la haie d'honneur
tu t'appelles de saint jean loubat menée
avec la grande tina turner field oublie
complètement le titre qui va chanter
regarde aileurs tina turner qui chat est
un petit chat du chauffard qui chaque
soir vous allez l'entendre tout très
[Applaudissements]
complexe merci m'avait c'était où c'est
ce qu'on a vu jean luc loyer maîtrisé
une interview en anglais n'ont pas plu
du tout pas du tonga était de selafa
nzuzi nos soba un peu alors cettex barry
white dans la haie d'honneur vous allez
voir qu'on a sûrement le même prof lui
et moi vainqueur
[Applaudissements]
la géographie
ouais si tu es originaire d'où je suis
ghanéenne de l'afrique l'ouest qu'à
l'est reconnaissait pas si vous avez 10
à la réunion bah oui mais c'est
tellement loin la réunion
j'étais fait pas dans un état alors si
vous êtes camerounais non gestion des
données
le club attend attendra donc à néant
mieux la carte gars comme la belgique
g